[Music]
time once again to do something us a lot
of fun called fan correction that is of
course a segment where viewers try to
find mistakes on our show we've been
doing this for quite a while so far many
challengers no winners
alright are the most accurate show on
television thanks a lot Randi your whoa
tonight tonight a fan named Mike thanks
he's caught a mistake he says it
happened during an interview I did last
week with Steve Martin they combed this
fight from Lou Costello I've been a fan
of yours for quite a while now and kind
of disappointed a mistake that you made
you said you were backstage pukin with
Steve Martin at Bonnaroo on June of 2010
really a couple problems on the still
photograph that I took you have
no beer I have a couple pictures of you
at Bonnaroo
you have a beard screwed up and just man
up to a family man say sorry Mike
but you're the one who has to man up you
are dead wrong I did not have a beard at
Bonnaroo last year you only thought I
did take a look at this exclusive
behind-the-scenes footage from just
before I went on stage at Bonnaroo
[Applause]
what you do need a beard that's hot
and I was tired of it you idiot there's
a 50,000 bona rulers out there who are
gonna want a beard here just glue some
of that to your face
our fans are so stupid they'll never
know the difference
you hold it up alright yeah yeah it's
gonna be great wait a minute
I'm so lonely that's right so the
challenge still stands for such a oh
yeah
that's right you were wrong Val last six
months on TBS I've had a ground-up paper
beard held together with tape [ __ ] so
so if you think somehow that you've
spotted an error on our show and if you
do we will man up
all right report it to team koco.com
slash ha ha I found an error we'll sort
it out right here on the air let's see
if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro yeah with
like a break we go back Demetri Martin